I need to hear that paper count paper
count I've gotta hear that paper count
paper count Warren Sharpe is in the
building in the building yeah just
another shout out to rob some before
that beat [ __ ] awesome Warren and I
we work hard so that you guys can be
smart rod simba works hard so that we
can start this off with some [ __ ]
energy Warren walked in today and he
said let's [ __ ] kill it today and I
said all we do is stack bodies that was
a little bit too much I did tell you
though Brian Westbrook's opinion about
chocolate and peanut butter and I've
never seen you that upset before yeah
it's it's I mean we can say what we want
on this podcast yeah free and open
airwaves yeah it's a [ __ ] terrible
paper and the combination of chocolate
and peanut butter is more pure than most
marriages yeah put it that way so I it
it really gave me a lot of pause when he
said it but I like being around people
that have weird opinions that's one of
the weirdest I've ever heard I didn't
know people actually could think that
way I do know some people don't like
peanut butter really because I think the
texture or some people might not like to
taste you know obviously there's kids
that are allergic to it yes so that's a
problem but if you're not allergic to it
and you are located with the texture I
think the taste is great and you combine
it with chocolate I mean yeah I don't
get it I want to kind of give you guys a
little look behind the curtain cuz this
is what me and Warren have been doing
for the last few weeks Wednesday nights
at around 10 o'clock we talked on the
phone we're supposed to talk for about
30 minutes we end up talking for an hour
and a half and really what we're doing
is we're doing the podcast before the
podcast and the reason is is we will in
that discussion discover things that are
actually kind of valuable and really
interesting to clean them up and deliver
to you guys today because we know when
it comes to looking at your lines and
and whether you're making wagers or
you're in some contests we want to make
sure we're getting to like really
interesting information and I think
we're both excited because we stumbled
on some things that we're gonna get to
later about teams coming off of buys and
home-field advantage that really go
against the norms of people thinking and
I'm excited to get to that but I feel
like you have an energy about not about
the card this week but about some of the
philosophies in Week five that are you
hitting your groove are your models
starting to give you some numbers where
you're feeling really confident right
now well okay the models are hitting a
groove yeah and and we're getting more
and more data so you stack the data you
stack the data and you have a little bit
more confidence but I am frustrated at
the same time so I'm upbeat but I'm also
frustrated frustrated I'm frustrated
about the number of two reasons first of
all the schedule makers put 10 games at
one o'clock
only two games again nonsense I mean
first of all you got a London game right
move the London game to 10:00 a.m. I
know it's the Oakland Raiders you're
playing in it they're not doing the
10:00 a.m. no they put the London at one
with all the other night thought that
everybody was complaining and I was like
it's actually 9 we're getting the London
game in the morning which is one of the
best treats a nice cup of coffee you
watch the Raiders get their [ __ ] kicked
in
I didn't realize they're playing it at
1:00 no and and then we only have one
four o'clock kick and one 4:25 kick it's
it ridiculous there's so I get I get you
know my huge theater downstairs with the
one big screen TV that has like all the
boxes on the 8/8 box for DirecTV and you
can only fit eight so then I have to
stick the two other games on the side
TVs which I'm built to handle this like
um this is what I'm built for but I like
rotating one extra game over all these
shows even one o'clock the issue is at
four o'clock if dead if Cowboys Packers
isn't a good game what the [ __ ] like
we're just sore stuck there watch that
okay is that the only reason you're
upset that's one and the second reason
is because of all these backup
quarterbacks in the games and the
coaches philosophies about the backup so
it's it's twofold you don't just have
the quarterbacks themselves who tend to
be a little bit worse
aren't as efficient but you also have
the coaches that decide to do things
less efficiently and operate differently
they get really conservative get very
conservative and we're going to talk
about a game that we saw on Monday Night
Football with the Pittsburgh Steelers
and the strategy they took and then what
might happen this week against the
Ravens but that was a prime example of a
team that just went Buber conservative
with a quarter but a less experienced
quarterback in there he's not even in
rookie he's just a less experienced one
it's it's unbelievable one little note
of confidence for everyone whose season
hasn't started as strongly as you would
have hoped Engler gave us the stat that
last year there are 12 playoff teams in
week five last year five of the twelve
were under 500 Colts were one in four
Cowboys Seahawks Eagles Texans all at
two and three and it's just look whether
the coaches break it down into quarters
the season whether they break it down
into halves
remember we the Colts were one in four
and they won like 1011 games in a row
the season is not lost it is not over
you're showing me the changing lines
Warren released some information and all
of Vegas is reacting that is the power
of Warren Sharpe do you is it fun being
this powerful in Vegas or did you like
it before where you were really below
the radar and when you gave out a bet to
everybody nothing changed there's pros
and cons to be sure but it is fun
because at least this way you're given
you're sharing information you see the
board move yes you know you're getting
the best of the number and then if the
board goes too crazy and other people
start piling on you can always like buy
back a little bit or position but we'll
talk about one of the games hopefully it
will make the 4 p.m. slate that we're
talking about as being terrible there'll
be a little bit more exciting yeah and
the thing that I always say is we really
want you guys this is not just about
giving winners when you really look at a
lot of the content on the internet right
now it's this notion that some guy is
gonna be really good at picking games
and you're gonna want to watch them
because they're gonna give you so many
winners and we're trying to be
intelligent enough to say no one can
consistently give you 70% winners all
the time that's just not how
whether you're picking sides or totals
it's not a thing that you can learn or
you can get but what we're trying to do
is let you guys look at the lines
yourself and learn what to focus on and
what to pay attention to so that if you
are out there making bets you're gonna
become a better better
don't rely on people to give you winners
because they can't try and learn and
it'll help you enjoy the games even more
we always start sharp school looking
back at last week what can we take away
what can we learn the first thing is
Holi Cleveland maybe they read all of
Warren sharps tweets because 11
personnel turned into 12 personnel and
those timely shots put a whooping on the
Baltimore Ravens and my question for you
is is this something that we can bank on
Freddie kitchens doing moving forward
and are we confident in that yes I am
I think the Cleveland Browns were
utilizing far too much 11 personnel and
finally they realized it I believe it
was Todd Monken influence that was
getting them to utilize too much 11
right and they weren't happy with their
you know they didn't have great tight
ends their health of the tight ends were
problematic but when they went back and
looked at the numbers and I was tweeting
out a lot of the splits
they were very bad when they were
passing out of 11 personnel and they
were passing out of 11 personnel on 91
percent of their attempts those attempts
delivered a 36 percent success rate
seven and a half yards per attempt what
they ended up doing against the
Baltimore Ravens is going much more 12
heavy and their 11 personnel was still
successful because we talked about it
before
Baltimore struggles against 11 right you
know three wide receivers spread them
out they've got injuries at the DB
position yeah spread them out attack
them however still work in some 12
because that's what Cleveland does
really well it helps give Baker Mayfield
protection yeah and it helps it's kind
of calm down that pocket for him and it
worked in its simplest form the game
that Ricky seals Jones had is because
they were in 12 personnel a lot and it's
just proof that in the NFL the margin
between a starter and a backup
is not always that wide and somebody
like Rikki seals Jones that a lot of
fantasy players but Mon how he was
supposed to be a breakout guy for
Arizona last year and it never happened
he's the kind of guy that can explode
for like 80 yards if your team is
running good personnel why are you
confident that this will continue
because it was successful because it was
successful and Freddie did it last year
so because the track record a track
record when he came to Cleveland one of
the biggest things that I noted was how
he helped Baker a lot with the way that
he ran that offense with doing a little
bit better things under center right and
also with the different personnel
groupings and because he did both of
those things Baker statistically right
started to just bloom and blossom this
past season the first few weeks we
weren't seeing any of that we were
seeing far too much Vennela 11 yeah and
now we're doing a little bit pre-snap
jump the running back from baker's left
to his right to dictate dictate a
matchup to that linebacker and then run
my tight end from 12 personnel across
the formation now the linebacker
coverages are messed up and this guy's
wide open for a touchdown um when you're
looking than at your models and we have
three weeks of Cleveland running all
this 11 do you then like reset your
models from here on out or do you still
factor in those three weeks where they
were maybe going to monk and heavy I I
still factor it in but when I'm mentally
looking at the matchups I will take into
consideration that they will probably
utilize more 12 personnel than they did
but I'm not gonna modify yeah anything
another team that one went very 11 heavy
in one of the early matchups was the
Eagles and and that was against Atlanta
and they did not have a lot of success
and then they go out against Green Bay
on Thursday night and I'm not gonna lie
I'm sitting there with a Packers fan and
every time I saw Dallas got it on the
field I went there in 12 big play coming
and in the beginning he was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about and then
as the game went on he looked at me and
he goes every time you point out Goddard
on the field with Earths Jordan Howard
has a big run where Myles Sanders has a
big run
and should I be confident as an Eagles
fan that this will continue because
Goddard was hurt and then this is what
they've always wanted to do is that how
you read that situation as well
absolutely I think that Doug Peterson as
at his core wants to utilize more 12
personnel they've had a lot of success
with it historically in Philadelphia and
they had success with it previously when
he was in Kansas City we also see it in
Indianapolis with Frank Wright yes
Peterson F and that does enjoy Oh Lindy
Braun yeah yep so is Andy you're running
a lot of 12 as well they they were
running a lot of 12 last year they went
to a little bit more 11 but remember
when they played the Ravens they went a
little bit more 12 heavy because of the
pass rush who was the other tight end
they put in with Kelsey [ __ ] I'm not
sure see these are the things we didn't
talk about yesterday I'll look that up
but but about the Eagles and the success
in 12th right so they used 11 personnel
prior to the game against Green Bay for
the first three weeks they used 11 on
80% of their plays and they only had a
44 percent success rate the average only
three point four yards per carry when
they went to 12 they using Blake Bell is
that the guy they're using ah el dozer
yeah I know remember the Bell those are
from Oklahoma right but anyway so they
reduced their 11 personnel from 80
percent down to 53 percent against the
packages used a lot more 12 personnel
they had a 69 percent success rate on
those plays in their runs average 6.6
yards per carry do you look at that as
oh the Eagles are better in 12 or the
Packers are more susceptible to 12 I
went into the game knowing that the
Packers were more susceptible to 12 so
when I I paid close attention to what
Dallas Cotters health status was and
because he only played nine snaps the
week before right so all these things
like if you're out there and you're
listening this and you're kind of like
betting on games and you're just kind of
you have to pay close attention to
different details like this like I cared
just passionately that Dallas Goddard
will get more than nine steps I needed
to know what his health status was it
was a short week he played not he didn't
play the week before he injured himself
in pregame warm-ups down in Atlanta
missed that game he only plays nine
snaps after
of rest and now he's going into a
Thursday night game on a short week is
he going to play a little bit more than
Rhine is he gonna be fully good to go
because it's a short week what's gonna
happen watching some of the practice
status reports listening to some of the
reporters talk right look like god it
was healthy Goddard would give me 12
boom Philadelphia Eagles team total over
20 and a half it hits in the first half
it's so funny because I went and I I saw
this miked up thing with Carson Wentz
and there's one part where he's standing
in the end zone and there's Earths and
there's got hurt and he look somebody
goes the band is back together and when
I hear that and then I think about how
you talk about it that's the core of the
Eagles we could talk about DeSean
Jackson we can talk about Al Sean
Jeffery the Eagles much like the Colts
are a team that if they can put their
two tight ends out there they can Matt
because goddard is so good in the run
game it's unbelievable and he's getting
better if I was gonna look at the
Packers then you just told me they're
susceptible to 12 do the Cowboys run 12
not out Witten and jar win together ever
no not not evenly like Darwin is
athletic I so oh that's interesting yeah
okay something we're gonna hit on later
so is that something you store away yes
I dive now that I've processed it that
in my research heading into this game I
knew that Green Bay was weak against 12
then I knew that Philadelphia was gonna
use a lot I liked Philadelphia right
then I store that in the memory bank for
the next game yeah Green Bay struggles
against 12 does dallas run a lot of 12
exactly where you're amazed don't do it
they don't use a lot now is Dallas an
11th yes so there are big three wide
receivers and they'll put out Cobb Amari
and devin Smith and then one of those
will be more they got Gallup now back I
think he's practice limited this
Wednesday okay we don't know what's
gonna be interesting but I could imagine
they like those three with Witten Zeke
yes and I would imagine Green Bay is
pretty [ __ ] phenomenal against 11
Gary of the corners and they're missing
Tyron Smith alright I'm getting a boner
okay now let's get to I think the thing
that we're very excited about
we established before the year that
home-field advantage is dead and you
have a laundry list of reasons that I
think are very pragmatic about why this
is the case and we can go over it teams
are used to crowd noise
traveling has changed so much what are
the other things that stick out to you
about why home-field advantage is not
the same as it used to be both of those
two things are extremely important the
travel thing especially guys aren't
riding in coach in the back of an
airplane they're spread out in charter
Jets and relaxing a little bit easier
there's better medical care nutrition
recovery all those types of things where
you know you're going on the road you
have to leave a day and a half two days
early you're getting there you're in a
hotel all those things used to be
impediment for the road team so if
somebody's showing you their car they go
I love a home dog
you're like it doesn't [ __ ] matter
that much anymore it's definitely not as
what it used to be you know and the good
thing is you know for the 33% we were
talking about this before the season
even started I did research and analysis
wrote an article up at shark football
analysis about this very concept about
the fact that home field is not worth as
much you're gonna give the numbers but
then the officiating is more neutral as
well you have back in the day back in
the 80s there TV coverage wasn't nearly
as good there was no replays there was
probably no grading of the officials you
know so like they were swayed by the
home crowd exactly and players are
making more money so that is going to
inherently lead them to take these road
trips as more of a business trip this is
gonna help my statistics my ability to
earn whereas before it's like oh how we
get to go to South Beach you know let's
let's pop some bottles tonight and yeah
there's better technology to to study
analytics game film on the road when
you're traveling and there's a lost time
know so if you look at last week week
for a straight up road teams were 11 and
4 and you go ok maybe that's just one of
those weeks where the road teams were
better than the home teams thus far this
season
I'm gonna give you week by week how the
road teams have done against the spread
week 167 percent week to 73 percent week
369 percent week for 60 percent the road
teams have covered the spread more than
60 percent in all four weeks this season
and I look at you and I go
was this an anomaly and I don't think it
is it's it's something that's been
happening more and more over the years
now this is super strong right it's not
gonna be over 60 you're not gonna get
Road teams cut going over 60 percent 80s
over the course of the season yeah at
some point it's going to correct itself
a little bit but this is certainly
notable and it what we need to carry
forward from like a learning perspective
is that home field isn't what it used to
be throw out some of these oh I all love
back in the home dogs they cover it this
a you know great rate yeah
wrote wrote Road teams are having a lot
of success so then we're talking last
night and I this is like an hour and 15
minutes into our conversation and I go
well what about bye weeks because I've
we've had a theory on this podcast for a
long time that it might lead to more
rust than rest and that's always like
the dumb [ __ ] topic bar on the bottom
of a television is will they be rusty or
full of rest and the first thing that
Warren said to me was it all revolves
around the CBA yesterday and explain
that to people just from a theory
perspective as what changed in 2011 with
the bye week that is impacting the
spreads right now yeah and so this is
where we're getting another layer into
everything in 2011 the new CBA came out
and that totally impacted teams
abilities to practice the coaches
ability to kind of like control his
players more he lost some of that
control the control went to the NFLPA
who bartered this deal and was able to
get more time off for the players and
less hitting for the players and so this
is one of the things that you must
factor in when you look back at
historical information also rules
changes that doesn't apply to what we're
discussing here but it's just the
concept that you can't just look back at
you know
oh well over the last 20 years X is is
the answer look at it in segments
understand the context of what's
happening so we ran the splits the UM
post CBA to like the years prior to CBA
and it's astonishing I can't wait for
you to share it so before the CBA was
signed teams coming off of a bye again
the spread this is this is from 2005 to
2010 they covered 60 - 60 61 63 4858 so
right around 60% of the time if you came
off a bye you were winning and their
lowest year was 48 percent of the time
they covered up for everybody then from
2011 to 2018 the cba goes into effect
against the spread after a by teams
covered 48 58 48:38 59 60 44:53 so they
had four years that were equal to or
below the lowest of what it was before
the CBA was signed and we dove in even
deeper uh it gets crazy and then I was
like well what about if a team is home
after a bye
the last two years a home team after a
bye covered the spread 18 percent of the
time I did not stutter I'll say it again
for clarity there were 22 games of a
team playing at home after a bye and
they covered the spread four times out
of 22 games
well Adam that's a too small of a sample
size we went back to 2011 home teams
after a bye cover the spread
41 percent of the time they went 43 and
62 well was it different than before the
CBA you bet your ass it was before the
CBA home teams from 2005 to 2010 after a
bye covered the spread 62% of the time
so before the CBA went into effect if
you were home after a bye you went from
covering the spread 62% of the time to
41% of the time when I hear these
numbers I go holy crap and then I turn
to Warren and I go am I making too much
of this and you went no this is
interesting it's very interesting
because we know the slimmest margins are
what wins in betting NFL 52.4% on minus
1/10 juice you're breaking even you're
not making anything off of it you go up
to the to the Pro
the pros through volume in terms of
dollars and volume in terms of number of
bets are hoping to hit 55% that's only
like a 2.4 percent a 2.6 percent edge
right here we're talking about moving
from a 41% up to a 62 percent blowing
right through the fifty two point four
percent mark just obliterating it it is
massive it is I think it's one of the
best nuggets that we've shared on this
podcast so far this year and so we're
sitting there we go well what happens if
they're on the road like what happens if
you're coming off the by on the road and
this was equally as shocking team to me
as I spit onto your shirt the last two
years after a bye if a team is on the
road they've they've against the spread
going 25 and 11 sixty nine percent of
the time a team after a bye on the road
has covered the spread well this needs
to be too small of a sample size let's
dig into it more we go eight years into
the past since 2011 teams after a bye on
the road are 83 and 57 59 percent of the
time they've covered and before the cba
it was just 55 and we sat there last
night and went how is it possible that
teams are this much much better away
from home after a bye compared to home
and we started getting practical oh
maybe they have to travel earlier in the
week so they're focused a little bit
more maybe that by continues a little
bit too far like far into it when
they're home but these are numbers that
I don't want to ignore these are numbers
that I want to think about now that
we're in our first week of team's coming
off of a buy that home team's after a
buy I'm probably gonna put them in my
card as a loser and a home team and away
teams I'm gonna think about it more and
go and we have a pretty good track
record here and I don't think I'm
reading too much into this no I always
look at trends as something to assist
and then you already like a team this
will push and get you over there in the
truck and get you to the edge possibly
of taking them it's not the starting
point but it is a point where you can
say you know what are the teams this
week that fall into the different bucket
and let me just be aware of these that
are that are a little bit more
cautionary like this is not working in
their favor yeah and let me look at
these a little bit closer because
they're in a great situational spot so I
mean the first thing I did this week is
I looked at the teams that were coming
off of a bi and the Niners are coming
off of a bi and they're playing on
Monday night football against the Browns
and I'm telling you man all week I was
like I love the Niners here and I saw
these statistics and it gave me a lot of
freaking pause you know it's interesting
they've got the Monday night game which
means like theoretically that buy lasts
even longer who knows if the coach is
typically a Monday night game you know
they come back a little I hate reading
into like player's personal lives but
like I follow a lot of miners and
they've really been living it up and
then I went and looked at the other team
coming off a bye it's the Jets yeah and
they're going to Philadelphia and I went
okay well we know teams after a bye they
haven't really been as good but you know
a way they've been a little bit better
and then I'm watching
Jamal Adams get interviewed yesterday
and Jamal Adams they go they go you know
have you been able to study a lot of
film in your off week and he said naw
hell no I went to Turks and Caicos I
shut it down you know I had my phone but
like I wasn't looking at anything
football and now I'm looking at these
statistics and that's the new CBA and
and I think about okay the Eagles just
played on Thursday night and they've got
like 10 days to prepare and they're
still in full grind mode and I'm here in
the starting safety a team leader
talking about men I haven't even looked
at [ __ ] film for a week and I go this
is why this is happening so I don't know
if either of the situations this week
I'm gonna put on my card taking
advantage of the Niners off of the bye
or the Jets with 13 mainly because they
have Luke Falk and I don't like betting
on Luke Falk but at the same time going
forward when you're coming up with your
bets and you go this team's coming off a
bye they're gonna be well rested give it
a little bit of thought and go it's
actually a disadvantage it is not an
advantage and there are numbers to back
it up yep absolutely yeah but it I don't
know that felt exciting to me because I
think it's it goes against the grain
that so many people believe agree and
it's something that I haven't heard
discussed publicly very often and it
also something that's a little bit newer
right because the sample sizes are small
so a couple years after the CBA you're
not really gonna notice these obvious
patterns but now that we have year after
year where it continues to happen it's
something to take it because my thing is
too is it's an interesting way of
looking at a news event and using that
as a tentpole as a dividing line because
if we didn't think about the CBA and we
just compared 2005 to 2018 the numbers
would be a mix yep but understanding
what legislation does to practice habits
travel games player rights it is
information that can be used in a
financial way and I think it's a
real-life way of looking at the NFL when
you guys see trends of teams that play
well on grass when they're when they're
starting quarterbacks initials RR cess
that's [ __ ] this is the kind of
stuff that you can actually use that's
why you have me here like you know how I
feel about you you're a [ __ ]
psychopath and you you bust your ass I'm
very excited the one thing that I think
that I've been focusing on is the juste
favorites line movements so let's move
to line movements and the one thing that
I saw heading into last week was when
there was a team that was a favorite and
in the look at headlines and they played
really well in their opponent didn't and
their line grew even further not
including Miami games they were 2 & 9
against the spread and I'm just peeping
at my attention on it now those teams
went one and two last week Kansas City
their line got juiced up didn't cover
Baltimore went from three and a half to
six and a half over Cleveland didn't
cover the only team that did was Seattle
facing Arizona so it's a one in two so
right now teams that their lines got
juiced up are now three and eleven
against the spread unfortunately this
week there's only two that have been
juiced up that's New England going from
13 to 15 and a half taking on Washington
and Philly where I saw some look at
headlines where it was like seven I
think that was like maybe of sand Arnold
come
back that's at 13 and a half but the big
lines are you like I've been saying on
the podcast I think New England wins
this game by 30 I think it's two decades
in the making of Bill a Czech building a
franchise and Washington just being
filled with ego when you're advising
people fifteen and a half is it too much
I don't normally take favorites that are
this large it's it's it's because
there's you have to be right almost like
60 minutes of the game right you
sometimes you can't afford to be wrong
that final backdoor cover where the
Patriots are up by you know 24 points
and you know you have to start worrying
about what's gonna happen if the spread
got a little bit higher so think about
this if there's one team to have
confidence that they'll play 60 minutes
it's the Patriots and the analytics a
lot of the years back it up where since
2016 when the Patriots are favored by
ten or more points on the road 501
against the spread they've gone eight
eight and two against the spread when
favored by 14 or more points over the
past five years but even the Patriots
didn't cover the spread against the Jets
because of a punt issue with olschewski
and Jamal Adams pick six so this is the
team that's most consistent when favored
by double-digits against the with the
spread and they still had a mess up this
year so that's why I'm just don't think
I'm gonna bet it this week it's tough
when you've got a spread that is that
high and so much has to go right and you
could have one play that screws the
whole thing up now that happens
embedding all the time one play is a
major factor at times but you know in
this case you really like it could you
could overcome it in other cases maybe
but in this case it's gonna be
potentially difficult and you know New
England is obviously a great team but
what is their motivation you know back
in the 2007 season right I was when it
was fun because they were making
statements and every single week and
here they don't really they just want
Brady to get healthy I was gonna say for
clarity of their like five biggest
spreads when they were favored by 15 and
a half or
or three of them were in 2007 yeah that
wasn't 17 was special 2007 was just a
fun season they were just dominating
people that was Randy Moss that was the
16 and oh right you know that was like
the bookmaker even at the end of the
year the lines caught up to them right
they weren't covering the spreads at the
end of the season but for so many weeks
they were covering and covering covering
the lines got bigger and bigger and this
team was just like if it was 27 to 3 at
halftime they're like this game's
halfway over let's put up 47 points no
and so they just kept trying to grow it
now it's a little bit more brady's old
we want to run the ball a little bit
more like let's play great defense let's
we don't have to go impress anybody make
points like yeah our goal is to get to
the Super Bowl healthy that was that was
a year where he said I have Welker
underneath I have Randy Moss over the
top and I have Krunk let's see what we
don't think they grow yet they're like
let's see what we can create
right now the Patriots our defensive
team just to wrap up the other team
that's the big favorite the Eagles just
if you're thinking about the Eagles
you're gonna play and Luke Falk just one
little trend to scare you a little bit
Eagles are oh and two against the spread
at home this season and their last 12
home games there are three and nine
against the Sprint there they just have
not been consistent at home it's a big
time spread against the Jets defense
that I think is a little bit better than
people think just scaring people a
little bit I don't want people to lose
their money it's appropriate you know a
lot about the egos they're your team
yeah they just they can start slow but
okay now one line that and really two
lines where we're kind of waiting to see
about the quarterback Chicago right now
the line was originally minus six and it
came down to five and a half with chase
Daniel in a weird way
i-i've been yelling all week that chase
Daniels not better than Mitchell true
Biscay like please stop it but from a
betting perspective I feel like it
actually makes you a little bit more
confident I was not that happy when we
were on chase Daniel last year on
Thanksgiving yeah the ultimately got us
to the window but I think they had to
score 14 in the fourth quarter
chase Daniel is
more familiar with this offense and Matt
Negi gives him more to do undoubtedly
but is he as skilled of a runner know
one of the most hilarious clips I replay
in my mind from the game last week is a
defenders approaching him and you know
how offensive player with the football
tends to do a little toe tap shake the
shoulders go around the guy right you
know make him go that way you go that
way
chase Daniels upper body is just totally
stiff his feets there going that depth
at that time he's not moving anywhere
and the guy just crushes him yeah right
that's chase Daniel okay so he's not
like Mitchell true Biscay from that
perspective and I don't think his like
he might be a little bit more accurate
but barely right it's he's not just like
a real big no step up or upgrade over
Mitch or Biscay he just can do a little
bit more with the offense but you if
you're betting on the Bears in London
there are going to be passes where he
were like what the hell is this guy
doing this is not a NFL quarterback
throw right from a guy who's making a
ton of money like like he's done who's
in the league the way I look at betting
chase Daniel is if it's a close spread
and I believe the Bears are more
talented team I think chase can get me
there but if these spreads start to get
really big and it requires the Bears to
put up points on people that's when I
lose confidence in Chase Daniel the one
note I will say to everybody about
London games I know that you guys
remember when Blake bortles who was
incredible in London beat the the Ravens
44 to 7 that was really one of the last
times that an underdog has beaten a
favorite in London favorites on a
neutral field I know you had this stat
for me are twenty and seven against the
spread 74% also favourites in London
since that game have beaten underdogs by
an average of eighteen point four points
per game when you are the better team in
London you absolutely stomp people and I
think I even have some of the games here
I'm just gonna go back in time this is
from this from that game so that was in
2017 Saints were the favorite they beat
the Dolphins 20 to nothin Graham
beat the Cardinals 33 to nothing Vikings
beat the Browns by 17 Patriots beat the
ravers Raiders by 25 Seahawks beat the
Raider the Raiders again by 24 oh wow
the Raiders don't play well in London
that's interesting
and then the Eagles won by 6 and the
Chargers won by 1 but if you look the
average margin of victory is crazy and
that's something we can bank on that
feels pretty consistent over the last
few years
I agree I think it's also interesting to
note just from a London perspective when
the teams are going over there you know
the Raiders played away from home last
week and then went directly over to
London right right remember they had to
send what's-his-name back vantes Burfict
back he had already flown over to London
then the NFL suspended him the rest of
the season justifiably so in my other
teams tend to go over there as late as
possible avoid all the distractions of
what's going on in London yeah who cares
like let the league write off you know
now that I think about it Jacksonville
who I think has mastered this they
always seem to fly over the day before
mm-hmm and then I think about all of the
media that I see coming out of London
right now and I'm seeing Raiders players
going around the town and I'm seeing
Raiders players interacting with London
fans and and try and you think about hey
guys this might be an intellectual
advantage they're not over there being
advocates and spokespeople they're back
learning right now just a little
interesting tidbit the only other game
that I think we're still kind of waiting
on the line is what is your philosophy
about the bills when it comes to like a
Josh Allen versus a Matt Barkley I think
Josh Allen obviously is better right now
than Matt Barkley and this is one of
those situations where I last week was
different because you're in the middle
of the game you have no choice what to
do right right so you've got a press and
you've got to go for it if you're
designing a game plan and you don't have
Josh Allen but you have matt barkley
that OC brian de balls are going to
design that game plan a little bit
differently difference so that's the
problem is like it's going to be more
conservative now i mean
is Josh Allen doin throwing all these
interceptions right unnecessary
ridiculous so maybe you don't get that
and could it end up working in your
favor that's what they're gonna hope and
so this is this is more of a
wait-and-see for you then just to kind
of see what yeah I got to see if who is
at quarterback for that but then also
it's it's tough because we don't know
what they're gonna do with Berkeley
we're I don't know what kind of offense
it's gonna be the only trend that I'll
kind of give to you is I looked it up
last 12 games at home for Tennessee when
they're playing a team with a winning
record they're nine two and one against
the spread Tennessee is Tennessee's a
good defense to the Tennessee can they
got enough big boys up front to kind of
slow it down but I don't like betting on
Tennessee games and I really don't like
betting on Atlanta games right now
they're just teams that I find them to
change week to week and from a betting
perspective I like teams that are
consistent not just to bet on but also
bet against because if you would have
told me that AJ Brown was gonna like
week one AJ Brown looked like Julio
Jones week for Ag Brown looked like
Julio Jones week two and three AJ Brown
like barely even played so when it comes
to betting like I have loved betting
Buffalo all year long but this is more
of an I'm an avoiding Tennessee and I
don't know the quarterback there's just
so many things I don't know that I cut
and I and I think a lot of people are
gonna bet Buffalo this weekend because
they're gonna go look what they did to
New England and I'm going who the [ __ ]
knows what we're gonna see on Sunday I
just I don't like the uncertainty
warrant that's I don't like it either
but that's the fun of this sport right
betting like this to me well it's the
reason why guys like me work our ass off
year-round studying the NFL so that we
can understand coaching decisions a
little bit more or be able to predict
what could happen so when somebody like
me goes there's too much uncertainty I'm
staying away from it you go let me dive
into that uncertainty and and they're
because they're so erratic I might
actually find some numbers that give me
a huge advantage yes do you promise to
call me on Saturday if you find an
advantage in this game I will definitely
let you know we text all the times yeah
okay so let's focus then on the the
lines that actually
moved a lot that are maybe interesting
first one we're gonna start off with is
New Orleans
Tampa Bay New Orleans I went look to
look a headline they were favored by six
and a half the line now is down to three
and a half and I think it may have even
moved down to three now when I went back
and looked at lines in which the
favorite has shrunk it's not enough but
the favorites right now are four and two
against the spread just from the look
ahead lines two now but that's not
enough of a sample size for me to get
excited and was this sharp money is that
is that what happened early on with this
line yeah this one was entirely sharp
money the New Orleans Saints I we were
on him you know two weeks ago in the
first half out in Seattle but they had
two non offensive touchdowns in that
game and last week I look at that game
and there's two big things that stand
out to be number one what the hell did
Dallas do differently offensively why
did they choose to get more conservative
to the use less play-action to run more
on first down because what they were
doing the first three weeks was not
their game plan week four against the
Saints number two was if Ezekiel
Elliott's elbow was actually down and
that ball is not a fumble the game's
totally different completely what I Nilo
I watched the review and it looked like
his elbow was down and the boy you know
was yelling about this Pro cause if you
think about it they had four field goals
and that that fumble led to a field goal
the end of the half and that's the risk
between winning twelve to ten and losing
ten tonight yes and and so I didn't
understand that call but the margins are
so narrow and when I look at this
matchup I'm looking at what the Saints
are going to try to do what have they
been doing with Bridgewater they're
probably going to do the same type of
thing Girondins in short passes right
runs and short passes what is the
extreme weakness of the Tampa Bay Bucs
and the extreme strength their extreme
weakness is deeper passes down the field
their extreme strength is best defense
in the NFL against runs and decent
against short passes yeah and so it's a
matchup where you're gonna push Teddy
Bridgewater's limits if you're Sean
Payton you're going to try to get him to
do a little bit more because
or you could go the conservative route
and do what you've been doing but you're
probably not going to score that many
points with that strategy then it's on
to Jameis and I think this game comes
down to the offensive line of the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers can they withstand the
pass rush and the pressure from that New
Orleans Saints front six they're so good
the Saints defensive line is so
underrated what's so funny is is we've
spent the last two decades marveling at
Tom Brady and Drew Brees and the
offenses and the offense of minds of
McDaniels and Payton and you look at the
Saints and the Patriots and the best
part of both of those teams right now is
their defense that's my fear about this
game is that the Saints defense is going
to be able to slow down Bruce Arians but
are you worried about that or as your
Analytics telling you differently it's
it's definitely a big factor you know
because if the best-case scenario is the
but if you are betting the box is the
Bucs
keep this game close have a slightly
don't have to press too much and do what
they've been doing and have success
offensively because the biggest you know
Brett Favre you know double agent type
deal in the entire NFL is Jameis Winston
right now his ability did well Josh
Allen's working his way up but Jameis
Winston thrown those interceptions
making dumb decisions that is a problem
and if you can prevent the need for him
to pass the ball as much because you've
got a small lead and you can be more
precise and and and specific as to when
you choose to pass and using play action
and finding optimal matchups I think
it's going to be interesting I also look
at you know the teams at the Dallas
Cowboys I'm sorry the New Orleans Saints
have faced so far this year and look at
some of the you know the defenses sure
what did you see well I see some edges I
see some schedule matchups we're going
to talk about some of that at the end
let's do it now let's kind of wrap up
this game to like what did you see from
the Saints kind of perspective and from
the Bucs perspective from who they faced
already this season all right let me
pull it up here I just the one the one
note I'll add to is New Orleans with
Drew Brees has been unbelievable in
October since week five of 2015 they're
12 and 1 straight out
in games in October but they've also had
a lot of trouble with this Bucs team
when you look at this this game last
year they lost forty eight to forty in
week one of the year before this is
again at home they were able to cover
but it's they they they also went to
Tampa Bay and they've struggled there
it's it's the last two years I feel like
Tampa Bay has kind of had the New
Orleans Saints numbers they have and
what I noticed first and foremost is if
you're looking at you know Tampa Bay's
offense against the Saints defense Tampa
Bay has the number 10 ranked offense but
they've gone up against the second most
difficult schedule of defenses so far
this season
if you Carolina Carolina San Francisco
week one
the Rams last week and the Giants
obviously one of the worst in the league
but it's it's been a treacherous
schedule for them and think about what
they did in those games I mean Jameis
does throw I think multiple two sixes
against the nine against the Niners and
that's all the Niners scored 31 points
but Tampa Bay put up 17 so you take away
those 14 points that's a game to go into
Carolina on a short week win they're on
the road as a dog that's very difficult
to do in the NFL they should have beat
the New York Giants right they should
have beat the New York Giants they
allows to Daniel dime's touchdown runs
they decided not that the field goal
decision with which Bruce Arians does
and then they go out to LA where Jared
Goff is better at home withstand the
tremendous passing day that Jared Goff
has 515 yards and and still come out a
victor there this is really a team that
is very close to being four no not that
not that many plays away from that look
at the Saints that's a team that's three
and one they came back from big-time
deficit week one against the Houston
Texans Drew Brees rallied in that game
they ended up winning that game they go
to LA they lose that game now drew Brees
gets hurt in there but they lose that
game they go to Seattle we were on the
Saints there but they had two defensive
or return touchdowns in that game they
only win the game by six points they had
two special special teams and then the
game in Dallas where that's a 12 to 10
game
that game could have gone either way one
play here are there I mean so like they
could be a team that's Owen four and if
the Bucks are a team that's four no
three and one heading into play Teddy
Bridgewater and the Saints with the
losing record that's a totally different
narrative on this game so you have to
look at everything in context I mean you
could go down the schedule I'm not
trying to say something that's make it
more than it is you could go down the
schedule of this play on that play and
this play then this seems undefeated in
sixteen you know you know I'm not trying
to say that I'm just saying in this
particular game there's I see the
justification in the line dropping from
what it opened out to where it is now
because I think that there's some upside
in the box it's very funny I literally
did on the Monday podcast I did what you
just did was looking at the Tampa Bay
schedule and going is this team secretly
making a run of the playoffs and nobody
wants to admit it because Jameis through
to pick sixes in week one and we have a
tendency as football fans to be very
persuaded by what we see early and it's
very hard for us to get things out of
our head and I think that the public
wants Jameis to fail a lot I think that
they've taken a lot of excitement in how
dumb he looked by eating the W I think
that that was dumb though they hey look
at they look at his play and they go
he's erratic he does dumb things but
they never look at when he throws for
four touchdowns in the 375 yards and go
that's why he went first overall and I
think there's this public perception of
him there's this public perception of
Bruce Arians kind of being like man I
didn't do what I do when I wear a Kangol
hat and they look at people like Shaq
Barrett and they go that's a flash in
the pan and and really they want to look
at the Saints and I also believe I said
on Monday that I think the Saints are
the best team in the NFC and I still
believe that even with everything that
you just said because they're not
playing with Drew Brees right now and
they found a way to get those wins and
so I think two things can be true I
think the Bucks can be severely
underrated and have a lot of value in
this game and I also think the Saints
are the better team and we'll probably
do better in the long run and I think
those two things can still exist and you
can have value in one game but not have
value over the entire scene
a hundred percent because it comes down
to matchups and in this game the matchup
with Bridgewater and the style that that
offense is playing currently without
Drew Brees does not match up well
against this Bucks defense could they
still have success yes that's why we
love the NFL any freaking thing can
happen on every given Sunday and we
don't know exactly if they're gonna
throw the ball deeper in this game will
they have success or won't they well
they will they get Taysom Hill involved
on somebody like we don't know what's
going to happen but that's what we're
gonna tune in and I agree with
everything you just said I I'm circling
Tampa as a possibility of going into the
super contests by the way I went for and
won last week
boom 14 and six overall and as warren
advised me last night we're just we're
going for three and two and fours and
ones we're trying to avoid twos and
threes and ones and fours yep
we do that it's hard it's it's funny I
circle Tampa Bay and I feel really good
about it right now and then on Sunday
I'll watch Sheamus throw I'll pick six
and I'll go and that's what I [ __ ] get
cuz that's that's the NFL but but those
things could happen you hope that if
you're betting on the box the game is
playing out such that he is not in the
situation where he would need to do that
but you're right I mean you see those
you see those Saints getting those
turnovers running the whole defense on
the field posing for pictures in the end
zone yeah it's something that gets
fixated in your brain and you hope that
one bad mistake from Jameis doesn't
start to snowball and two to three Kazan
yours totally screwed UH one game the
other game that moved a lot in terms of
the spread was Kansas City went from an
eight and a half point favorite to Indy
to an eleven point one but um I say
we're gonna talk about that in the next
segment because that is the Sunday night
game so let's move to the three biggest
games of the week and we're gonna focus
on one of the one o'clock games of the
frickin ten that are there the four
o'clock game that is gonna get the most
attention and the Sunday Night Football
game and the one o'clock game that we're
gonna focus on is the Ravens Steelers
would you say when you're wagering that
you find teams that you kind of get a
read on and you try and bet then
throughout the season because you really
have a good grasp of them do you find
yourself doing that some
time's yeah you'll go with a certain
team for a few straight weeks because
you feel like they're being undervalued
because that's what I think our
relationship is right now with the
Ravens where every week we're looking at
the Ravens and you've been all over
other teams abilities to really maximize
their efficiencies of defending three or
more wide receivers and so Ravens
Steelers Ravens are two and two coming
off a drubbing at the hands of Cleveland
I wrote it down in my book find a way to
battle in Baltimore this week and the
reason is is I love when a really good
team has won bad game and everybody
jumps off the bandwagon people were
tweeting at me Warren are you finally
gonna stop saying the Ravens are good
and I said no I'm actually doubling down
because I watched that game and I saw
the fact that it was 10:00 to 10:00 in
the third quarter and I saw the Mark
Ingram fumble that let the Browns score
two quick touchdowns and when the when
the Ravens are down 24 to tenten that's
a different Ravens team than when
they're 13 to 13 or 16 to 13 and then I
watch the Steelers game and I'm going oh
my god that's who the Ravens are playing
next week and they're playing Zach
Taylor and the dumbass Cincinnati
Bengals who are down three possessions
and running out the clock and I'm going
this is setting up perfectly
it may be an overinflated Steelers team
and an undervalued Ravens team and what
you saw in that game from the Steelers
and the Bengals may be coaching
malpractice by what they're doing right
now to Mason Rudolph excuse me what
they're not doing right now with Mason
Rudolph to prepare him what did you see
that you thought was poor coaching from
the Steelers the Steelers decided
instead of using the week after the
49ers game to better prepare Mason
Rudolph for the rest of the season he's
not a one-week filling he's your
quarterback now instead of preparing him
to do what it takes to win in the NFL
which is to maximize the rules and a
leverage which is throwing the football
down the field instead of working on his
ability to do that they spent the entire
week with gimmick
while cat crap and courts so everybody
is praising jaylen Samuels and how
creative the offense is and you're like
you're taking the ball out of Mason
Rudolph hands you want to get this guy
ready to throw the football down the
field that's how you're going to win if
you're going to win you are not going to
continue to win games doing cat passes
from running backs I mean that might
have caught Zac Taylor's team off-guard
right but it's not going to catch the
Baltimore Ravens off-guard
and you know I got a couple takes on
this game but the first and foremost
when it comes to the pittsburgh steelers
is what exactly do you think you're
going to do and surprise the baltimore
ravens with the style of offense because
this is what the baltimore ravens
practice against every single week since
the summer with Lamar Jackson British a
Russia is a rushing offense it is an
offense that of the Ravens that lines
guys up uses motion tosses the ball to
people read options and that's exactly
what the Steelers think they're being so
clever with doing and that's not going
to work against the Baltimore Ravens
will they try to change it up and do
something different I don't know the
goal needs to be spread out the
Baltimore Ravens defense and let Mason
Rudolph throw the football but will they
do that I think across the board of many
teams out there the Pittsburgh Steelers
are a team that ignores analytics the
most does what they want to do tries to
trust their talent our talent is always
better where our talents going to
overcome and the problem is your talent
has been severely depleted you don't
have a B anymore
say what you want about him he was super
talented when I was playing you don't
have Le'Veon Bell anymore James Conner
is good too yep but is he quite as
talented I'd rather lay view on and
James then James and Jalen okay do you
don't have Ben Roethlisberger you know
now juju is your number one as opposed
to your number two all of these
different cyberghost touchdowns or a
dump off to Jalen to James Connor and a
wide open throw to it was a Deante
Johnson yes down the left just wide oh
that was and how did he caught the ball
like he was fighting against somebody
tugging it in he like jumped up and like
two wrestled the ball out of the air so
yeah just catch the ball buddy but
you're but you're seeing right now a
team that is not supporting analytics
not preparing their quarterback to go
forward and
this this offense that is about you no
change of pace and a lot of different
formations they're going up against a
team that might be the most prepared to
face it of any team in the NFL a hundred
percent what is one of the big issues
with the Baltimore Ravens right now that
John Harbaugh is very upset with his
pass rush our pass rush isn't getting
there what do you do when you line up a
running back in the backfield and he's
passing it to different other guys you
don't need to frickin pass rush it's a
run right so you're not attacking the
weakness of the Baltimore Ravens defense
which is they don't have many good D B's
right now because they're banged up and
they're passed rushes week because of
offseason losses and instead you want to
go run heavy so I don't know what
they're going to do and this is where
it's hard we're handicapping the coaches
what do we think is going to happen but
if they use that game plan that they
utilize last week I would be shocked if
it worked as successfully in this
particular game and and like you said
when you believe that a team isn't using
analytics it's actually easier to bet
that they're going to continue to do
what they do because they're not going
to see water to change also the one
thing I'll say is is the Steelers were
able to get such a good pass rush
because they were playing Andre Smith
who is his ain't Brandon thaw Byrne is
that the guy that does a lot of the
offensive line defensive line breakdowns
he doesn't feel like a star thorn excuse
me I believe he said in one of his
articles that Andre Smith might be the
worst player at his position in the NFL
which when people in the analytics
community take a take like that I love
it so much but also like Andy Dalton the
frustration on his face on Monday night
the amount of times that he got sacked
and threw the ball into the dirt and in
my mind he just looked like a guy that
had completely given up he had no
opportunity and then I go and the same
guy that focuses on offensive line
Brandon says that of all the left
tackles in the NFL right now Ronnie
Stanley from the Ravens is performing at
the highest caliber
JJ TJ Watt and and the end bud Dupree
are not going to have a lot of success
getting a pressure on Lamar Jackson and
even if they do he'd [ __ ] Andy Dalton
he ain't going down right away and we've
seen when teams have time against the
Steelers defense
they tear it up they just didn't have
time with the Bengals that's why all of
our expectations of the overs their play
calling sucked and their talent on the
offensive line sucked and those are not
the issues for the Baltimore Ravens
offense at all no and let's not pretend
though that Andy Dalton was good even
when he had time he was he was a
disaster as he typically is in primetime
etc but when we talk about the Baltimore
Ravens and we talk about what their
offense is going to look like and we say
well why does this offense look
different now the answer is simple when
they fall behind in games they end up
having to use more spread themselves
they pass more out of 11 personnel so if
you look on the season their average
success rate from 11 was a 45 percent
success rate passing and they only
averaged six point six yards per attempt
prior to this game but they only passed
from 11 58 percent of the time they're
mainly using 12 and 21 and different
formations heavier sets when you are
trailing you have to put more wide
receivers put more wide receivers on
number one and number two the defense
isn't really caring if you're gonna run
the football I'm writing down in game
betting Baltimore if Baltimore goes down
early and the game flow changes they're
gonna be in trouble but if they get a
nice little head of steam and they're
able to use multiple tight ends watch
out I looked it up in the last five
games at Pittsburgh including a playoff
game the Ravens are 5a now against the
Sprint putting that out there we've got
to move on I'm talking too much Packers
at Cowboys is the four o'clock game both
teams are three and one Dallas
plays against New Orleans unable to get
that offense going we're going what the
hell happened Kellen Moore the Packers
Thursday Night Football were able to
really throw all over the Eagles but
they got run all over the big injury
here Tyron Smith not gonna play for
Dallas what sticks out to you in this
matchup
what is going to occur with Kellen Moore
why why did he utilize an inefficient
game plan was some of it Jason Garrett's
influence
because what we saw I hope seemed like
Jason Garrett's influence let's run the
ball more on first down let's use less
play-action I am hoping that Jason
Garrett is one of those people because I
know that he's obsessed with chefs key
that lets his assistants to their job my
fear is that that was the first real
defense that Kellen Moore has faced on a
prime-time game and he got real tight
yeah that's what I'm hoping it is the
thinking it is but like you said we
don't know no we don't and the other
issue on the other side of the ball well
then you got the tire and Smith factor
in that as well and they didn't do well
without Tyra and Smith out there on the
field in previous seasons so that's
going to be a challenge they do get
Michael Gallup back that's going to be a
big boost on the other side of the ball
the Green Bay Packers don't have Davante
Adams that's a big loss right I'm pretty
positive that he's not going to play
this week I don't know if it's under
percent confirmed we'll watch the injury
and the Green Bay Packers you look at
their scoring by quarter first quarter
28 points second quarter 33 points third
quarter
14 fourth quarter six that's over the
entire sum of all quarters this entire
season they have really good scripting
and they do well offensively in the
first half they make terrible
adjustments in the second half it's
impossible that it's just their
opponents that are just so great at
making defensive adjustments laugh time
that every single game these defenses
are shutting this offense down I think
it's from a coaching perspective in a
play Paul calling perspective they need
to this Dallas Cowboys team can put up
points if they play efficient football
right you can't do well in the first
half and then go into a turtle shell in
the second half if you're Green Bay but
that's what they've been doing you I
feel like both of these teams kind of do
that I feel like both of these teams can
establish leads in the first half and
then both get very conservative in the
second half and I don't know if it's out
of fear out of Blatt bad play calling is
that something we can take advantage of
it all we could we need to analyze it
and incorporate it into what we're
looking at but I don't know in this
particular case that there's a specific
advantage to be had for
that it's these coordinators are both
new both in their first year they have
very talented quarterbacks and they have
good receivers out there on the field
they should be trying to stay aggressive
offensively but it seems a little high
to me for these new coordinators facing
like I wouldn't looked at the strength
of schedule Green Bay it's like the
Dallas offense in terms of defense as
they faced against the pass it is a 22
drop in terms of strength of schedule in
terms of how much harder it's going to
get for this Dallas passing offense and
the one thing that Dallas can do that
Green Bay has shown is Green Bay is a
run funnel team they're able to take
away the pass which I air Alexander and
all their safeties and all that but what
the Eagles were able to do was to pound
the rock the fear I have is what you
talked about earlier is Green Bay's run
defense is susceptible to 12 and Dallas
doesn't run 12 so we'll see what happens
yeah the Sunday night game this is the
game where I said the line moved from
eight and a half to 11 the Colts are now
11 point underdogs at Kansas City how
much of betting this game is going to
determine is going to be riding on the
health of Darius Leonard and and and
injuries to the Colts the Colts have to
part they're both starting safeties
potentially will not play Wow and their
middle linebacker right one of the best
in the best wide receiver so if we look
at the defensive side of the ball for
the Indianapolis Colts you're going up
against a team that's very creative was
passing to their tight ends and to the
running backs like your DBS are
important they're always going to be
important but against an Andy Reid led
team the strength of your safeties and
the strength of your linebackers in
coverage for running backs is maximized
and that's really why Detroit had
success because Justin Coleman was able
to be such a phenomenal slot corner and
take a while out of those middle routes
in the middle of the field right and
then on the other side of the football
when
you don't have T Y Hilton what did the
Oakland Raiders do against this team
last load up that box baby loaded up
force sit on every were set to throw it
over the top two guys who aren't capable
of beating one-on-one coverage down the
field and and we already know that T Y
Hilton splits outside of a dome or awful
so even if he does play he's not dome T
Y Hilton no yeah because I I'm not gonna
lie man do you know how many people in
this office came up to me and said 11s
too much further the Colts and that's
that's too big of a line for a team like
the Colts primetime against Patrick
mahomes could get really dangerous
it's the Colts are a totally different
team because how did Detroit have
success last week we knew they could run
the football we know Kansas City defense
struggles to stop the run so Detroit was
able to run the football control the
game a little bit use some of the
passing over the top down the field
they've got good wide receivers they got
a quarterback who can throw the deep
ball and they had success with that what
does this Indianapolis Colts offense not
have right now this offense in general
is a much more condensed ball control
passing offense that will run when they
can but they're not going to run as much
as Detroit does and when you don't have
a guy to take the lid off the defense
can come up and play the run a little
bit more frequently and have more
consistent results so I'm not suggesting
a move one way or another I haven't done
anything with this game but that's the
that's the give you you need to have if
you're saying the Colt +11 seems so good
to be true I also want to say that if
you're a better and you're saying out
loud this seems like too many points
don't [ __ ] take that side like you've
always said if you don't think this team
can win the game outright the points
don't [ __ ] matter you do not bet an
underdog unless you believe they can win
the game outright
and there is a game flow possibility
that is absolute Anarchy for the Colts
Chiefs go up 7-nothing and you can sit
at home and go I can see that happening
and then the Colts go three and out and
the Chiefs score again I mean this might
get it really empower the Colts gonna
come back how are they gonna come back
in without to you I yeah you could talk
about that offensive line all you want
who were the weapons to get you back at
eight and i heem hines you know it ain't
Jack Doyle
so you need a perfect game flow for the
Colts to really be hanging in this game
because Patrick mahomes will do whatever
he want okay I don't think I'm gonna I
don't know that's a really good one okay
is there are there any other games that
have really caught your eye in terms of
spreads I know there was one out west
that you were kind of wanting to talk
about a little bit that gotta got you
excited yeah let's talk about the four
o'clock game where the Denver Broncos
are gonna be taken on Packers Cowboys
yeah the game that like the NFL wants us
to focus on let's not focus on that one
let's focus on the other one because
there might be a little bit of value
don't be distracted by the man behind
the curtain exactly so so Denver right
now what is the line on that game well
you could get seven now it's there's a
bunch of sixes popping in the market but
there's still some six and a half and I
believe at the West Gate for the Super
contest at six and a half right okay
so I look at the Denver Broncos and I
don't like Joe Flacco I don't like that
guy as a quarterback I mean I thought he
got he timed it perfectly made a bunch
of money on that contract has never
lived up right and has never lived up to
that was a mistaken cause the Baltimore
Ravens to really fall back when you're
paying a quarterback that much money and
he's not doing anything for you then
you're gonna be in trouble
I feel the salary cap coming but so far
this season he's actually done better
than his numbers for much of his career
he's got a career high completion rate
career high he's got his yards per
attempt highest since 2010 its passer
rating highest touchdown rate highest
and interception rate the best although
since 2014 right so last four or five
years he's doing really well and he's
faced one of the most difficult
schedules of opposing defenses eight
toughest schedule of opposing defenses
so far this year Jacksonville
Green Bay Chicago Chicago and then
Oakland that first week Oakland the
first week which was you know what but
Green Bay Chicago Jacksonville that's
like the hardest three-game slate in the
league this year it's brutal now janely
Ramsey wasn't they sure that we're on
the road two of them were on the road
very difficult places to play very
deaths on one of them
sorry okay you throw me off without that
was my bad I apologize the one game was
in Green Bay and then Chicago and
Jacksonville both went to Denver right
and in this game this is the easiest
past defense that Joe Flacco will face
this season Wow
so the charges right now are in disarray
in their secondary do you know what Josh
Rosen did to this defense I did see the
clip of him throwing a touchdown to PJ
Williams but I did not focus on the game
what did he do in this game against
against this Chargers defense Josh Rosen
in the first half he completed I want to
say 12 of 16 passes nine point nine
yards per pass attempt and like 106
passer rating something like that he was
remarkable in the first half now the
second half caught up to him obviously
we know the Dolphins don't have a lot of
talent there but he was moving the ball
up and down the field and as I'm looking
at this Chargers defense what do we need
to have happen here if we're gonna back
the Denver Broncos we need to be able to
take some pressure off of Joe Flacco by
running the football that's step one
when you go on the road we need a run
game to come with us
can they run the ball here and the
answer is yes the LA Chargers struggled
to stop the run specifically from 11
personnel oh that's not good when Denver
runs the ball from 11 personnel which
they do above a league average rate
they're averaging a 62% 62 percent
success rate gained four and a half
yards per carry what do the Chargers
allow to 1162 percent success rate and a
40 which is well worse than the 48
percent league average when I think
about the Chargers this year you know
what I think about tight ends and
running backs having a lot of success I
think about week one I think about
Marlin Mac I think about some of the I
think about last week Kenyan Drake had a
very nice game against them last week
and I think about Phillip Lindsey and I
think about some of the plays I've seen
that of Noah Fenton heuerman they have
that personnel so you're you're feeling
something here well you know I think
that the Denver Broncos have a good shot
offensively they've done well the Green
Bay Packers were a team that was
similarly weak against Iran
and the philip lindsay killed they went
for like a hundred and sixty yards on
the ground in that game had a pretty
good success rate they were down three
and turnover margin and joe flacco got
sacked 6-times so the number one thing
you got to be able to do with joe flacco
let's get a run game going number two
all these pressures and sacks and hits
we got to be able to do a better job on
the offensive line
well they got JaJuan James one of their
tackles he missed the game last week
he's coming back this week is really
he's practicing on limited basis that's
a good sign conceding practice at all
last yeah number two look who's the
Chargers gonna be missing Ingram oh he's
probably out for this game he is out I
know he's out okay so you don't have
Ingram your secondary is cluster
injuries and you can't stop the run even
with Ingram there who's really good edge
rusher and in a league where home-field
advantage doesn't matter you have the
least amount of home-field advantage
playing in LA yes yes absolutely and so
all of those things work in the favor of
the Broncos offense here a little bit in
a game where they had it sewn up last
week against the Jacksonville Jaguars
until 17 to 3 until Jacksonville saw
something on film or saw an injury to
Chubb who's going to be missed in this
game yes and started to run the ball
more out of 12 personnel and they just
were battering down that's where Leonard
fournette got all of his big runs
they had a 71 percent success rate
average like over 10 yards per carry
running out of 12
but the Chargers don't really run out of
12 very much at all and if you look at
the Chargers health they probably were
going to enter this game from a wide
receiver perspective healthier than
where they were last week because they
do have Mike Williams practicing on a
limited basis and they do have Benjamin
practicing on a limited basis both those
guys didn't practice at all last week
and miss the game against the Miami
Dolphins that being said they are not at
a hundred percent it's still to be
determined if they will or won't
practice and the leading target guy last
week for the Chargers he just got put on
IR what what's the wide receivers name
you just got put on IR it's escaping my
Oh Inman Dontrelle I just got put on IR
okay right now the
three healthy wide receivers on their
roster who are practicing in full Keenan
Allen geremy Davis and Andre Patten
those are their three wide receivers and
they used to make that last name up I
almost I'm I I to look up the guys who
are on here those guys are there
starting three they run a lot of 11
personnel and they're without Hunter
Henry as well right and you know what
bad offensive line and you know what
franchise probably uses less analytics
and the Pittsburgh Steelers
yeah the Los Angeles chargers yeah the
Chargers I mean that's been a struggle
for them I think they're getting a
little bit better but it's still not up
to par of where it needs to be the
Broncos got back Kareem Jackson I think
he's gonna play this week you missed
last week he's a cornerback
JaJuan James hopefully will play for
them as well and then last but not least
Keenan Allen is going to be probably
shadowed by Chris Harris when Chris
Harris has locked up Keenan Allen the
last three games that they've played
really this is what Keenan Allen's done
one catch for five yards in a touchdown
two catches for 22 yards and no
touchdowns and six catches for 69 yards
and a touchdown you know what's so funny
from like a football player perspective
Keenan Allen's greatest ability is quick
movements and and short bursts and
that's what Chris Harris has special is
he's not a long Strider everything is
short everything is compact he was for a
few years the best slot quarter in the
NFL and you just think from a matchup
perspective Chris Harris is just like
underneath Keenan Allen visually
physically it all matches these guys
have a little rivalry I mean this is
these are division by division rivals
that I love betting on underdogs and
divisional rival games right so anything
could happen your bank you're betting on
Joe Flacco if you're taking the Denver
Broncos right you're betting on Joe
Flacco but guess what else could happen
but what say it what Joe Flacco could
going to LA and finally win a game and
it just might happen I mean you got me
betting on [ __ ] Joe Flacco and Jameis
Winston this week this is sick I love it
all right so I'm gonna that was awesome
you literally convinced me on that one
here are the the liens I'm going with
I'm gonna take your Denver in your Tampa
Bay those are gonna be two of mine plus
six and a half plus three and a half I
love the Ravens minus three I like the
Bears
- five and a half going to the London
and then my fifth game is one that I'm
gonna watch all my injury reports
I like the Vikings against the Giants I
just saw that say Quan might try and
play this week
I don't know why no I don't like saying
I don't need it also the Vikings I also
see Stefon Diggs secretly wanting a
trade so I might stay away from that one
Packers plus three and a half is
interesting Browns plus three and a half
because of what we were talking about
with the Niners is very interesting and
the only other one I'm looking at is
Panthers - three and a half
Kyle Allen's first home game this year
he's - and Oh both of those games have
been on the road and I look at
Jacksonville and I go okay you know they
beat Tennessee at home on Thursday night
great and and okay Leonard fournette had
200 in whatever yards against Denver
last week but the offense hasn't looked
that great and Carolina's past defense
is unbelievable so that's probably what
I'm gonna circle right now I'm just
gonna pay attention to the injury
reports but those feel clean to me feel
really clean I'm just you know I'm
worried about betting on Jameson and Joe
Flacco well you also bet on the more on
the road you're also bettin on in London
so you've got you've got a lot of kind
of and Kyle Allen yes so a lot of a lot
of inexperienced quarter s to be honest
with you that's the frustrating part of
this whole board the frustrating part is
a lot of inexperienced quarterbacks in
these games yes and we talked about it
before it's not just that they're
inexperienced but then is what are the
coaches going to do are they gonna put
him in avocation situations that's one
of the things that I like about what the
Turner's are doing in Carolina with Kyle
Allen because they're putting him in
more advantageous situations to be able
to pass efficiently and building the
offense around his strengths they're not
saying don't throw the ball would this
be conservative he needs to work on his
ball security he needs to work on his
awareness yes but as a passer he's doing
a great job of executing the offense
that they've got better than some of
these other guys are doing I don't I
don't dislike your card and I do like
the Carolina Panthers in that spot okay
I have had a few people DM me
hey I know that Warren gave out a coupon
code last week for sharp football
analysis is it still good I'm just gonna
ask you to your faces it's still good
uh the code is sharp ten okay sharp ten
okay and you'll get a discount on
everything that we have up at your
football analysis comm fantasy sports
betting props we got a lot of props
going this week yeah and what I'll say
to you guys is what I do on Saturday and
Sunday morning I go there I click on
dashboard and I do two things I look at
the bets that Warren feels confident
enough to put out to his people and the
thing that I appreciate about Warren is
you don't pick every game you know you
pick like the five things that you're
most confident about two might be two
unders one might be an over one might be
a site like you might only pick one team
in terms of a side bet but that's when I
hit up my guys and I go hey Warren's all
in on this but the thing that I
appreciate about your site a lot is if
you do use shark 10 and and subscribe is
it's not just the pic then I get to
click on it and read the 18 paragraphs
about how Kyle Shanahan against
Pittsburgh was the only dude in like the
last decade to score over 30 points and
then you know and it made a lot of sense
for that but there's there's really good
write-ups so you go there sharp ten you
get a discount was it ten percent off
everything I'm percent off everything
and that's coming up here one of the
coolest thing is that I love doing and
that's why we dive into games with you
and go over the things the same exact
way I love sharing my logic about why
I'm backing something because bets win
and lose all the time pick six a fumble
what have you it's the process that
really matters it's understanding why do
I like this and sharing that with people
and detailed write-ups and so I'm up
talking to you until 2:00 a.m. last
night yeah sleep till 4:15 wake-up call
get ready to take the train up here and
I'm on the train two cups of coffee deep
in there cranking up for two hours
writing up one of the games that I'm
sending out so I'll absolutely love
sharing that and anybody that has ever
put money on a game the greatest feeling
is going wow this game flow is going
exactly as I thought it would be
now could you get backdoored absolutely
could could chase Daniel throw a pic and
like it [ __ ] up everything or and and
it gives it bad field position
absolutely but when the game is going
like you think it's going to go that's
why we talk like this because then you
sit there on Sunday and you go not only
do I understand it from a football
schematic but from an analytic and then
also just from an understanding game
flow perspective the right side doesn't
always win but you want to be there
because it feels so much better yeah if
you get line value and then stuff starts
going your way you know that you're a
notice undone you have done your job you
can't do no job of the players you can't
do the job of the coaches but you have
done your job as a sports better because
you've put yourself in this situation to
make money on this game and that's what
it's all about it's about putting
yourself in those situations putting the
work in so that you are in those
positions that's why we like to talk
about our losses too because you can
learn from your losses
let's give crack a call let me enter in
my proxy bets and we'll see if he has
any other picks that he'd like to make
okay so we're gonna call him this went
from a card that I didn't really feel
confident about and then you gave me two
little nuggets and now I feel pretty
confident I still don't like the card
overall but there's a couple spots of
value Hey crack a deck what up brother
hey what's up guys what's going on
just chillin just kickin it grab it's
great to talk to you because you are
doing better than anyone I personally
know in the West Gate super contest to
let you know fourteen and six your guy
Esposito txt I mean he says I guess
you're not lucky you're actually pretty
good at this I'm trying to I believe in
superstition man so I'm trying not to
jinx myself no you're doing you did
you're well ahead of even the Dozen
sharp guys I know you have a better
record than all of us so that's on that
and hopefully going for you to continue
that when I see these two guys that are
19 and 1 and 18 guys that are 18 and 2
it just blows my mind though all
Psychopaths
before we get into a little bit of
betting advice I know that you have a
strategy in terms of concert tickets and
I know that someone may have given you
the tickets to Arrowsmith but like I
kind of like your strategy for getting
like two feet from the stage do you want
to share that or would that ruin your
little your little thing here
well listen it's all about who you know
and legis is still a town where you fold
up hundred dollar bills in your hand at
the people hopefully get a better seat
sometimes so this particular concert I
didn't but I mean that it's all about
that when you go to a show first of all
you should always buy concert tickets
last day because last day the scalpers
and the brokers they freaked out oh my
god they're gonna get stuck with first
row seats or even second or our first
tier seats which are much more expensive
face value so I always wait to that day
and it's always good to show up with
$1,000 cash and put it in their face do
you want to get rid of these two Lady
Gaga seats in the third row for a
thousand bucks oh you want to hope
someone else is gonna buy them with you
and and and it works a lot I mean I've
gotten first row The Rolling Stones for
face value and and it's not a little bit
maybe a little a couple dollars more but
well you told me this or triple the
price crack would so funny as I'm the
guy that would buy concert tickets six
months in advance and when you told me I
was like I'm an idiot I'm only gonna buy
day oh so you don't just get betting
advice you get concert advice here are
the five that I'm gonna go with as of
right now again I will text you if I
change but I feel pretty good
Ravens minus three at Pittsburgh Bears
minus five minute okay okay I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you were the first one
went in and out Ravens minus three at
Pittsburgh Bears minus five and a half
in London I'll let you talk about those
two yep
well the Bears didn't one of those teams
want to be there so yeah I have no
problem with you going with listen
Oakland looked really good last week
after the travels Chicago I know they
won that game neither team probably
wants to be there I have no opinion on
that game but I want to be rooting for
you
he's in Baltimore yeah Baltimore - three
well Pittsburgh got there I think that
was their first win last week and
I like betting against teams after they
win crack it's my it's my drug I look
there's a line Baltimore - three yep it
came down to three I don't have to worry
about that a half point because it's
three and a half here to some spots -
three - 20 is the best line I see so
just mathematically Baltimore over
Pittsburgh there and Baltimore's coming
off of a terrible loss to Cleveland they
they try to re-do we just lose crack all
right so we lost crack we don't know
what's going on with the phone as I
already said though I like Denver plus
six they have to have a plus three and a
half
Panthers - three and a half just a shout
out for crack he does have the crack
wins app he has his picks he has tips he
has strategies and cracks a good [ __ ]
guy and he just gave you some concert
advice I feel like we taught a lot of
people about buys that is something that
I'm gonna be paying attention to for the
next few weeks teams coming off a byes
and taking advantage of that I think you
had some incredible Nuggets today about
that game in the lates late the the New
Orleans game and then also we're gonna
we're gonna keep watching these backup
quarterbacks keep seeing if coaches are
gonna be very conservative see if we can
take advantage of some of these under
plays I know that it's been more unders
than over as this year and then as as
Warren Sharpe said sharp ten if you want
to check out what he's gonna do this
week if you want to kind of get a little
sample and see what he's working with
sharp ten little discount code did we
give the 33 percent what they needed
this week mr. Sharpe I think we put in
the work we put in the homework to get
this show as much actionable information
as possible yeah and I think we really
nailed it I really hope that they can
learn from it because there's some stuff
that you were sharing with those
statistics and trends that I have not
heard anybody else discuss yeah and I'm
hopeful that we'll start tracking it and
see how it goes this season Warren has
all the answers I just have a shitload
of questions together good [ __ ] comes
from it follow him online at sharp
football me and Adam
Co and let's just pause really quick for
this beautiful sound of money for Warren
sharp on the lef koe me in and we will
holler at you guys a little bit later
these huh
[Music]